we welcome you back to the academy
theater and the takeoff so good to see
all of you
[Music]
lately i've been seeing in special
effects movies there's been more of an
attempt to bring in real practical
aspects to it and not rely completely on
cg for let's say the particle systems i
was very taken by the use of helicopters
and the dust how important was it to
have some real world placeholders for
that sequence in your mind uh it was
pivotal today's brief to me from the
very beginning was that like you wanted
things to be as photo real and as
grounded as possible he never wanted the
audience at any particular point to be
actually taken out from the story now
obviously we're building these space
worlds and flying ships and stuff so it
was very much an approach of like trying
to keep
virtual cameras as if you were able to
shoot them so basically you never got
too close to an autofocus because
obviously you would crash you know we
shot helicopter to helicopter we did
take off and some landings with
practical helicopters to then change
into ornithopters we also built two
12-ton ornithopters which we try to use
as much as possible in camera and then
add cg rings even though there are parts
where are all cg they're always bookend
with a real shot so the idea was to try
and keep everything as grounded and as
flooded well as possible
[Music]
almost every shot has some photo real
visual effects some sort of graphical
element and sometimes some transitions
between the two it's an amalgamation so
we literally watch thousands and
thousands of hours of video game play
and all of us have our people that we
know that play endless hours of video
games so
we just collected all the information
and you know tried to pay homage to it
put as many easter eggs in there as we
could so that's why some of it's
photoreal and some of it's just playful
so half of our company are technical
advisors when it comes to video gameplay
i was taken by how well the integration
between visual effects and practical in
that sequence how did you work together
to make that work obviously the first
thing was to get the aston martins the
choice was easy because you know that's
bond's car what wasn't so easy is going
to western martin and asking for 10 of
them buying them wasn't an option
renting them wasn't an option so
we quickly settled on we would have two
real cars and eight that would be built
by aston in conjunction with us all the
car stuff was a really good
collaboration between stunts vfx and sfx
and i think we looked at every shot shot
by shot to see how far each department
could go and so broadly breaking it down
it was you know the wider shots was
mark higgins driving the car us
replacing bodies or heads were required
getting closer we're painting pods out
but we've got the real talent inside the
cars and then process work obviously
after that to get even closer and so it
was kind of horses for courses yeah
[Music]
ah
you said you had to sort of create all
those backgrounds
you couldn't go on location to shoot
that can you tell us a little bit more
about that because they're so beautiful
and so effective that you just don't
know that
you didn't have at least a good
foundation to work from for your
environment before you added all the
amazing visual effects work there were
many backgrounds or worlds out there
that we were hoping to go to and then
covet hit digital domain then took
incredible photography that they had
just of that area and then rebuilt that
whole world macau we were supposed to be
shooting an entire sequence there so we
ended up building that city from scratch
it's amazing what you can get from uh
google maps these days the world of talo
sue the art department build an amazing
set just outside of sydney australia it
had about a dozen houses but the entire
world around it is obviously all cg
there's an opening shot you see in the
real when you fly up over the bamboo and
reveal tallow for the first time and i
think it's it was a beautiful work by my
rising sun it was it was great
the entire world's about to forget that
peter parker is spider-man uh
can't some people still know we're not
throwing how the spell works and it's
very difficult and dangerous to change
it in the cast
the portal opens
it's reflecting on the actors it's on
the surfaces
just some of the best i've seen of that
what's interesting about the interactive
lighting in general like with uh first
with the when the spell goes wrong
sequence and we didn't really know what
it was until quite late in the process
gaffer's asking me so how do you want to
light this
how do you want to do this interactive
lighting and i'm like well just kind of
keep it neutral not too high frequency
kind of just keep it general something
that we can manipulate if need be we
also for that sequence built a digital
version of it so that we could light it
interactively as well
and of course with the end battle in the
powerline corridor sequence a lot of
that's just a cg environment
but with jamie foxx he was lit also
interactively but we're able to tie that
in generally speaking with what we had
so great great stuff thank you
thank you my fellow governors as well as
the entire academy team your tireless
dedication effort made this event
possible tonight there's a lot of people
working behind the scenes to make this
happen so thank you very much
you